donc 7e ça reste bien mais il n'arrête
pas d'être déclassée en ce moment sur
condom voidray mais c'est pas tout vous
dire il faut être bon le jour j
regardez-vous on répète vous fêtiez
mauvais comme un cochon alain et
aujourd'hui vous à quoi voit ya par des
cochons hier voilée
pourquoi le cochon pour ne pas lever la
tête baissée en fonction de sa colonne
vertébrale il n'a pas de vertes avaient
tous donc il peut effectivement palme
mais elle est là les terribles
cauchemars elle rappelle gilles bernès
quand il était petit des mères
japonaises jean michel maire est là
comme une vraie partie de dingue
24 heures plus tard hier c'était pas le
moment donc vous attend demain mais vous
n'aviez pas d'infos ici mais j'ai pas de
regard vous êtes passé à autre chose
donc j'ai attendu attendu bien
génériques du marbocyl loyer ou un
générique de tapas et d'autre et michaud
il y avait julien courbet derrière aller